[Music]
Okay, time is up. Please bring your
quizzes down
since Yeah, don't worry about it. Throw
it away.
bring your quizzes down,
please.
Yeah. What was the email
applied? Okay. What was it that you
asked me to do? I haven't even looked at
my my emails are piled up today. Yeah.
Been teaching all
day. So, you didn't do the quiz or you
did do the quiz.
Okay. Yeah,
we did all three quizzes. Your worst
quiz will automatically get weighted
less. Did you miss the first quiz? Okay.
And the promise this quiz will count.
Yeah. Okay. Time is up. Please bring it
down. It's right or wrong. Then
basically the promise I can't give you
partial credit. So I'll give you
whatever I
can.
Right. Okay. Time is up. Please bring
your quizzes in. Please bring your
quizzes in. Time is
up. Don't worry about it. We're limited
recycling.
Don't put it face
down. Make it more difficult to sort.
So, time is up.
Okay,
folks. If you're still writing, time is
up. Bring your Don't put it face down.
Don't put it face
down. Put it face up. Right on
top.
Okay. Time is up.
You're okay. Over.
Okay,
folks. Get settled in.
Time is up. Please be
Don't put a face down.
Okay. So, there'll be people coming in
from the other class. So, let me let me
at least set the
stage.
Okay. So, last Wednesday after I
finished teaching your
class, I went to JFK airport. I took the
A train. No, it takes forever. Got to
JFK airport and
um folks, the quiz is done. No point
talking about it. It's over. Okay.
What?
It It happens every time. So, it's
natural. But, okay, folks, settle in,
please. Quiz is over. If you want to
talk about the quiz, please leave the
room.
Hey guys at the back, if you want to
talk about the quiz, you can leave the
room if you want, but if you want to
stay
in. So last Wednesday after I finished
teaching this class, I took the A train
to JFK airport, I got on the flight and
while I was sitting waiting for the
plane to take off, I was breaking the
rules and checking my iPhone still not
in airplane mode. And I was checking the
Yankee game to be quite honest.
U in process and I said will they win
will they not and of course I got the
news story coming in as I was checking
the Yankee
game about the tariffs right let's face
it we have no choice but to talk about
the
tariffs so I spent you know Saturday on
the flight back I was great looking at
evaluation projects didn't get a chance
Monday all day I was you know graded.
Then I at office hours at 6:00 when I
finished with my office hours for the
quiz I started writing about what I
thought about what had happened over the
week. Okay. So Jake, help me out here.
There was a tariff announcement on
Wednesday. I mean we've been talking
about tariffs all year, right? So what
made this tariff
announcement so shocking to markets?
Clearly markets were shocked. So what is
it about the tariff? Go
ahead. Okay. First magnitude, right?
People are expecting. So
second, no, we'll come to that. But it's
it was breath. I mean, take a look at
the map, right? You think, but there are
parts of the map that are not covered.
You know the parts that are not covered.
North America where you have Mexico and
Canada which have had a different set of
tariffs and of course Russia and North
Korea which are technically under
sanctions. So the tariffs wouldn't. So
it was the breadth and the depth and of
course the basis for the tariffs.
Sophia, what was the basis for the
tariffs?
It's basically tread deficits, right? It
wasn't a reason that matters is there's
no easy walking it back, right? If it
were based on tariffs, then the other
country can say, "I'm dropping tariffs
to zero." The EU today offered to drop
tariffs to zero. Vietnam has offered to
drop tariffs to zero. But dropping
tariffs to zero is not going to make the
trade balance go away. It's a trade
deficit that's scaled on a percentage
basis, which means smaller countries are
going to have bigger percentage. Vietnam
will have a much bigger trade deficit on
a percentage
basis. So the market got a hit, right?
It had a pretty good Monday, Tuesday,
Wednesday, and of course you wake up on
Thursday and the bottom falls out. So
this is the S&P, the Dow, and the
Nasdaq. All had a pretty bad two days.
The Nasdaq was down 10%, the S&P down
9%, the Dow down 8%. So across the
board, the problem with indices is you
look at subset of companies, you know,
30, 500, even the NASDAQ. So during
COVID, one of the things I started doing
every week was downloading the market
cap for every publicly traded company so
I could aggregate and look at the
numbers, right? So that's what I did on
my, you know, as I got on my flight to
come back, I said, you know what? I'm
going to download the data of every
publicly traded
company. And here's what the numbers
look like globally, right? The US had a
bad two days, but so did much of the
world. In fact, the part of the world
that had the worst two days was what I
call small Asia. The small is probably
misnomer. It's Asia without India,
China, and Japan. the rest of Asia which
would be Southeast Asia Pakist so
basically it's Thailand Indonesia 12
down 12.61% 61%. The US was next. And if
you look at the two markets that
actually had the best two days was China
and India, but that's a little
misleading.
Why? There's a simpler date a date time
issue that comes in which is those
markets closed by the time
Friday's markets opened up in the US and
went through the day. India and China
had already closed down. The market's
already closed down. Which means that if
you're going to see an effect, it'll be
when you open on Monday. I haven't quite
looked because I've been busy all day.
I'm pretty sure that they probably
opened on an down note today. Kind of
catching up. There's a lagged effect.
So, this is across the globe. So, I
wanted to slice and dice the data to see
if this was panic
selling. So, if this is panic selling,
what would I see in the data? Where
would I see it in the data? What kinds
of companies should go down the least?
What kinds of companies go up the most
or go down the
most? Anybody want to give that a shot?
If it's panic selling, what should you
expect to
see? It's not even because at this pay
point people are not even thinking
discretionary, nondiscretionary, but
you're right that is going to be part of
it. But you should see a flight from
risky companies, young companies, high
PE companies, growth companies to safer
companies, right? Flight to safety. So
here's the first thing I did. I look by
sector. So I'm going to focus just on US
companies because Thursday and Friday
were more complete for them. I'll do
this on a global basis as we go along.
So by sector, worst sector, no surprise,
it's actually
energy. Why? Because oil prices went
down a lot.
The next worst was technology. And if
you look at dollar value, it's no
contest. Technology alone lost $1.8
trillion in market cap last week. All of
it on Thursday and
Friday. So across the board, every the
sector that did the best and this is
slightly you know s supportive of a
safety hypothesis was utilities down
4.4%. Everything was down, but utilities
were down less than most of the market.
Collectively, US equities lost $5.3
trillion last week. All of it on
Thursday and Friday. Where did it
go? You ever wondered when the market
drops, where does the money
go? I would love that to be true.
Where? Where? How does the government
collect the drop in the money? That'd be
great if you could because that'll make
our deficits go away in a hurry,
right? What happens to it, William? It
just disappears into thin
air. Remember, we talked about what
markets do assess a value for future
growth. They put that into the It
basically disappears, which is the
scariest part of this. $5.3 trillion
just evaporate. Oops. Just evaporated
over those two days. So don't think of
this as people cashing out and moving
the money. It's just not there. It's
gone. I also then looked at whether the
damage was greater at small cap versus
large cap because if it's truly panic
selling, you should probably see small
caps punish more. There's really no
difference. It looks like across the
board across market cap
classes, you know, it's it's 9.51 versus
9. That's you know statistically pretty
much the same
number. There is some evidence of safety
when you look at companies broken down
by PE ratio. So I looked at you know
classified every company into 10 deciles
based on PE ratio. The lowest PE stocks
were down 8%. The highest PE were down
11%. So not a huge shift but it can see
that lower P stocks held their value
better than higher PE
stocks. But let's stay on the safety
theme right? If safety is what's driving
it, companies with a lot of debt should
have gone down more than companies which
have less debt. Right? Turns out that
the reverse was true the two days. Maybe
because of the technology overlay,
companies with the least debt actually
dropped by 9%, companies with the most
debt were down only 8%. Okay, not a huge
difference, but you're not. So if
there's a panic story here, it's kind of
a blurry story because there's some
evidence in support of it, some not. In
fact, when I broke it companies down to
dividend paying and non-ividend paying
companies, dividend paying companies
actually went down by about 9%.
Non-ividend paying companies went down
by 10%. Again, the difference is pretty
small. I mean, I'll gather all the data
together, but you're not getting huge
divergences like you did in 2020 between
different groups of stocks. And finally
the question I asked was maybe this is
just you know correction of overpricing
last year. If that is the case what
should you expect to see? The stocks
went up the most last year should be the
ones that get marked down the most. So I
classified stocks based on
momentum. Momentum defined as what did
they do last year. So the low bottom
desile the stocks that did the worst in
2024. The top desile stocks that did the
best. Look at the last column right? The
stocks that did the best did h actually
have the worst few days, but
collectively not a huge difference
again. So, was there a flight to safety
last week? Yes. Was there some panic
selling? Probably, especially on Friday.
But this doesn't look to me like what
you would expect with a true panic
selling where effectively you leave
risky stocks and you go to at
le 7. Why? Because they've taken over
the market, right? And I owned all seven
of them. It's, you know, at the start of
this year Tesla I left early in the
year. Invi I have a quarter of what I
own. The remaining five are in my
portfolio. So this is purely selfish.
The mag seven just those seven companies
lost
$1.56 trillion in market cap last week.
I mean let the I mean let the numbers
roll around. 1.56 trillion gone in one
week. And it came after they'd lost 2.6
trillion leading into the week. So
collectively this year the MAG 7 have
lost 4.1
trillion. But last week they look very
much like the rest of the market.
Leading in they look worse than the rest
of the
market. But the equity market are only
equity markets affected by a crisis.
What is the you know if there is cash in
your portfolio? If you do get cash from
selling stocks which is a lot less than
what you see as the the original market
cap where does it go someplace safe
right and for better or worse
historically that place has been US
treasuries. So in most crisis what
should you expect to see cash coming
into US treasuries and if they come in
yields should drop. So I looked across
the
spectrum and again the backing for the
safe the flight to safety becomes pretty
weak because you look at the table rate
it decreased by 0.05%. Even at the
longer spectrums
02.25.3%. So there was cash coming in
but not such large amounts that you saw
a major shift down in rates.
So the and I did pick three very odd bed
fellows to look as my last table. Oil,
gold, and bitcoin. Each is standing in
for something. What's oil standing in
for? Commodity prices, right? And why do
we care about commodity
prices? Because markets use that as a
reflection of what they think is going
to happen to the real economy. Oil
prices were down 14% last week. So
better or worse, investors are expecting
a slowing of the global
economy. Gold of course is a collectible
of really longstanding and the reason
you look at it is you want to get a
sense of you know is this truly a crisis
where you're running for safety because
you're running for safety gold should go
up. Gold did not go up but it held its
own. It was down only one and a half%.
And I was surprised by Bitcoin because
through its
history, what's Bitcoin done when
there's a market
crisis? That's not what's true. That's
what the Bitcoin people would like you
to
believe. During a crisis, you'd like it
to, right? Okay.
The first quarter of 2020, you remember
that COVID crisis? Stocks were down
33%. Awful crisis. Gold was up 6%. You
know what Bitcoin did in those that
first quarter? It was down
57%. Between March and September, stocks
come back 45%, Bitcoin was up 70%. You
can go back and look at every crisis in
the last 15 years and every
crisis, Bitcoin has behaved like very
risky stock which undercuts a whole idea
of Bitcoin is where I'm going to go in a
crisis because you know I don't trust
anybody. Yes,
Sophia. Yeah, there's an interesting
question. What? This is the first crisis
that I've tracked in the last 15 years
where Bitcoin has actually gone up.
Maybe this is the start of a new dawn
for Bitcoin advocates. You're going to
become the go millennial gold finally
that you've been praying you can become.
But it's early in the game. Let's see
how this plays out because I think this
morning Bitcoin was down
$7,000. So, let's hold off. It might be
a little too early to pass judgment on
it, but I would track that because if
Bitcoin is going to hold up as a
collectible, it's precisely for times
like this. And if it doesn't work now,
then what the heck are we paying $90,000
for Bitcoin for if it's not a good
currency and it's not a good
collectible? So, if I were to summarize
based on the data what I see, I see
selling. Obviously, everybody sees
selling, price are down. I don't see
much evidence of this being while panic
might have been some factor. It seems to
be more like a marking down of equities
saying equities are worth less now after
this new story than before. It's more of
an orderly retreat so far at least. And
of course that could
change. That's where we are. So anytime
you're in a crisis, you get caught up in
this. What do we do now? So, what I'd
like to do is take a step back and think
about how crises play out, right? So,
I'm going to draw a picture of what I
see during a crisis. Every crisis,
there's usually a trigger event,
something, an economic, a political, a
financial event that starts the ball
rolling. I'll give you a couple examples
as we go through. You're investors. The
trigger event happens. What's the only
thing you control as an investor?
the what you do which you can buy or
sell. You affect the price, right? And
if you're getting scared, what do you
do? You lower the price which is
essentially a higher price for risk.
Your risk premium goes up. So the
immediate aftermath, investors mark down
risky assets, put their cash into
something safer and then the aftershocks
begin. What are the aftershocks? The
trigger event creates other
events, right? Counter events. Events
counter to counter events. Market drops
create their own dynamic. When markets
drop, if you're a levered investor, what
do you have to do? You've got to sell to
get your cash back because you got to
pay the debt. So market downturns create
this trickle effect where they play out.
So the the aftershocks like an
earthquake, the aftershocks continue for
weeks after the trigger event, which
means mark and those aftershocks can be
positive or negative. Right? This
morning there was a rumor. You see that
that that the tariffs might be paused.
Completely made up. Stocks added 4
trillion in market cap. 4 trillion on
the rumor. They gave it all up. Get used
to volatility because that comes in the
aftershocks. Eventually, does this kind
of play out in the real
economy? Yeah. Why? Because consumers
get scared, businesses get
scared, economic growth slows down. So,
there's a real effect. there's an effect
on the real economy in the near term.
Could it affect your long-term prospects
as an economy as well? Depends on the
trigger event, right? It could change
economic dynamics, real growth and
inflation the long term, which then
feeds back. So, it sounds abstract, but
let me take two crises and trace you
through the consequences.
Let's take the 2008 crisis triggered by
the collapse of Lehman Brothers on
September 13th and 14th, a
weekend leading into Monday, September
15th. If you read the the the the book
series of unfortunate events, usually
before the trigger event, there are
series of unfortunate events where you
look the other way. I mean, this wasn't
a complete surprise. Bear Sterns had
been in trouble earlier. Housing prices
look shaky. But this was the seinal
event. You had Leman fall. The markets
go into freeall. In the two weeks after
the Leman collapse, stocks lose about
20% 12% of their value. Rates treasury
rates drop. But it doesn't stop after
two weeks. It continues.
In fact, you know, by the time you get
to the end of 2008, stocks had lost
about 28% of their value and treasury
rates had gone from 3.72% to
2.21%. What were the aftershocks there?
I was around in 20 I was teaching this
class in 2008. I remember week to week
there were rumors of hey Morgan Stanley
might go under, Goldman Sachs might go
under, Cityroup might go under. Luckily,
it didn't happen, but there were these
aftershocks that played through. Hedge
funds were shutting down because they
had fund flows that were so strongly out
of the funds, they could not essentially
sell to keep up. Money market funds
broke the buck. You know what that
means, right? You put a 100,000 of money
market funds, even if you don't make any
money, what do you think? I'm going to
get my money back. In 2008, you put a
100,000 in. There were weeks during that
crisis where you're getting 98,000 back.
GE at that time leading commercial paper
issuer in the country could not find
people to buy commercial
paper. It played out in the real
economy. You enter into
recession and by itself you're saying
why do I care as an investor? Because
recessions a slowing of growth
translates into earnings and the S&P
500's earnings dropped by 40%.
That's a short-term effect. But it this
crisis had long-term consequences where
banks stopped lending. It took 5 years
for S&P 500's earnings to come back to
what they were
pre208. The 2008 crisis had long-term
consequences. And one of the
consequences was we lost trust
collectively in institutions, in
governments. It's a 2008 crisis. On
September 12th of 2008, I started a
process that in hindsight I wished I
hadn't. I started estimating the equity
risk premium every
day. So every morning I'd wake up, it's
depressing thought, but I'd compute the
implied equity risk based on the closing
price the previous day. Why? It's the
only way I could keep my sanity because
you listen to the voices around you.
They're going to tell you sell now, buy
now. It's all over the place. So there's
the equity risk premium on September
12th of 2008. There's the equity risk
premium on November 21st of 2008. Hit
8%. This is the equity risk premium for
the S&P
500. That's what a crisis does. The
price of risk essentially takes
off. By the end of the year, equity
risks were at
6.43% about 2% plus higher than they
were at the start of the year. And you
know what? Equity risk premiums did not
go back to pre208 levels until last
year, 16 years it took to get back. So
this is a crisis with both short-term
and long-term
effects. Let's take a crisis that's more
recent that you remember perhaps not in
the financial market sense, but in a
personal
sense. February 14th of 2020.
You know what the new story was that
triggered this whole process? It was a
new story from Italy saying that they
discovered multiple COVID cases in Italy
without any
connections to China or cruise ships
because until that day the delusion was
if you weren't in China or weren't on a
cruise ship then the pandemic wouldn't
come for
you. And over the next few weeks you saw
the market meltdown. the first week to
again you saw 10 12% but by the time
this was done on March 23rd of 2020
which is what less than 6 weeks after
that first date stocks had collectively
lost a third of their value 33%. The
T-bond rate which had come in pretty low
to begin with 1.62% had dropped to 76%
by the time you get to March
23rd. Were there aftershocks in the case
of COVID? What were the
aftershocks? News about health scarce
across the country as well as news about
businesses that might not be able to
make it because they were shut down.
They couldn't pay their
employees. Boeing was rumored to be in
bankruptcy by the time you got to the
middle of 20 middle of March of
2020. Was it the real effect in the
short term? Yes. The economy went into
recession. If you remember, the
unemployment rate exceeded 20% in May or
June. though it's not even clear what
that unemployment rate even measures if
nobody's actually opened
up. But here was the difference between
2008 and 2020. By September of 2020, so
the earnings dropped for that second
quarter. But by the end of the year,
it's almost like nothing had happened
because the economy came back. The
unemployment rate started, it finally
got down 2021, but it started moving
down. But this was a crisis that unwound
very quickly.
And you look back and say, but a lot it
was probably helped by the fact that you
had multi-t trillion dollar government,
you know, funding for people who were
who didn't have jobs and a central bank
that was very activist. But for better
or worse, it unwound very
quickly. So there again, I did what I
did in
2008. I computed the equity risk premium
every day. There's at the start of co
March 23rd, it hits close to 8% 7.8
8%. And then by September, it's back to
where it was before the
crisis. Price of risk shoots up during a
crisis. And in this case, it very
quickly went back
down. Now, whenever you have a crisis,
people read too much into it. They in
fact draw all the wrong lessons because
they look at the crisis and they draw
lessons. When you look at those two
charts as an investor, what's the lesson
you draw if you're an optimist?
Uh that markets go down but they
eventually return. So if you're a
contrarian investor with a long-term in
no time horizon, what will you be doing
right now? You'll be putting buy orders
like they were going out of style,
saying, "Look, I know my history." But
the fact that a catastrophe did not
happen doesn't mean that the probability
of a catastrophe happening was zero all
the way through. Do you see what I'm
saying? The fact that we came out of
intact was not guaranteed in October and
November. In fact, if Morgan Stanley had
gone bankrupt as well, followed by
Goldman Sachs and City, you'd have had
like, you know, bank after bank failing,
you'd essentially have gone into
financial hell. It didn't happen, thank
God. But the fact that it didn't happen
doesn't mean that it couldn't have
happened. Could co have evolved in a
much more damaging way? Yeah, the fact
that it did not doesn't mean it could
not. So from an investor perspective,
don't look at those graphs and say that
means I will just go buy these stocks
because of the tariff and they're going
to always come back because there's
always that possibility of a
catastrophic event. When regulators look
at at crisis, what are they trying to
do? They're trying to figure out what
they can do to prevent the next crisis,
right? They're looking for people to
blame, people to hold accountable,
passing laws and regulations to stop it.
So after the 2008 crisis, banks were
restricted from risky activities because
they were viewed as behaving
badly. Ratings agencies had new rules
put on them to get But the problem is
you're dealing with a symptom. The the
incentives that led banks and ratings
agencies to do what they did never got
fixed. But regulators think you fix the
symptoms, the problem goes away. And of
course, researchers go crazy after
crisis because with the benefit of
hindsight, what do they say? If you're a
behavioral economist, you point to a
crisis, say, look, these are irrational
investors. Look what they did. Look at
the correction. If you're an efficient
market person, you look at the same data
and say, look how amazing the market is
and managed to find its way back. But
you remember in statistics what you
should not do with a sample size of one.
Don't extrapolate too much. Every crisis
is different. And I'm not sure I I think
the mistake we make is we overlearn from
past
crisis. We read too much into the tea
leaves when in fact you should step
back. There are things to learn, but you
need to know when to
stop. So let's look at where we are on
the tariff crisis. What's what is the
trigger? The Wednesday announcement,
right? That was the trigger. Thursday
and Friday is the first phase. But if
history is any guide, what does it tell
you? The next few weeks are going to be
rocky, right? They're going to be and to
get used to plus,000 days, minus,000
days on the Dow, right? Because that's
the nature of volatility. When you're at
32,000, 33,
34,000, you're going to get a lot of
aftershocks.
there going to be positive aftershocks
with you know some country you know
today I read the news story after
markets close that Japan might come to
an agreement with the US about tariffs
and markets might react positively 15
minutes later you're going to get
another news story about another country
putting extra tariffs on a markets will
go down this is the nature of the
aftershocks the probability of recession
which was I think estimated to be 20% on
Wednesday by Friday had been up to 50%
by I think JP Morgan's most recent
estimate. So clearly people are
estimating a greater chance of a
recession. Doesn't mean they know what
they're talking about but clearly people
are much more concerned about real
economic growth. If there is a positive
coming out of this is inflation which
has been at the center of the universe
for the last three
years. The positive the economy is
slowing. I know there's going to be a
one-time jump if tariffs kick in on the
price, but that's, you know, that it
might actually make the inflation threat
dissipate or at least go into the
background. What about the long-term
implications?
First, is global trade good for global
growth or bad for growth? Let's you know
without bring clearly they've been good
for growth, right? It's econ 101, right?
So basically, so if you put restrictions
on global trade, whatever those
restrictions are, by definition, the
global economic pie is going to get grow
slower. It's going to get smaller and
the US economy as the largest piece of
that pie is also going to get smaller.
You think this is a slam dunk? Then why
do it? because you could change the way
the pi is aortioned because that might
be the other consequence. For the last
years, that pie has gone
disproportionately to capital providers.
What am I talking about? Equity market
investors have clearly benefited over
the last 40 years. Their slice of the
pie now is twice what it was 40 years
ago. The pie is a circle. If I take
twice two slices for myself, somebody is
getting less, right? So who's been the
who are the players who've lost in this
process? There's econ, there's labor. So
clearly over the last 40 years, there's
been this. So the argument might be that
the pie is smaller, but there will be
some people who will now get a greater
slice of the pie. If you look look if
you listen to what's coming out of the
White House, they're not even trying to
talk the market up, which is unusual,
right? Historically, whenever you've had
a market crisis, what does the Treasury
Secretary do? come in and soothe fears
down and try. Notice that there's almost
no attempt on this
one. It's almost like they say, "Look,
we're okay with the pie shrinking if we
can get a different aortionment of the
pie." Long-term, I don't know how
that'll play out, but that seems to be
the inside game in
Europe. So, I've started estimating
equity risk premiums by day. And I know
I'm opening up a Pandora's box because I
have to do this every day. Now for how
long? For until I get to be comfortable
again. That might be weeks, months from
now. The market closed today. So after
the class ends, I'll do the update for
today. And I'll have to do this tomorrow
and day after. Even the thought of doing
this is exhausting. But I have no
choice. So this is the start of the
graph. And 3 months from now by May 6th
you will see it start to take form.
Let's see if it looks like a co graph in
terms of rising equity risk premiums or
is it going to level off? But the only
way to find out is do it every
day. Now will there be aftershocks?
Absolutely. Will the real economy show
it? I think that whether there's a
recession or not, the economy will slow
down. I think inflation fears are going
to get lower.
Long term, I have no idea. As I said,
the pie will get smaller, but who gets
what slice will still get played out.
It's as much a political fight as it's
an economic
fight. And doing all of this, I have one
piece of advice. Stop watching
CNBC. I'm supposed to be on tomorrow.
Don't watch me. Right? I don't want to
be on. The only time I actually watch
CNBC is in the four minutes before I'm
on. I have to watch, you know, what's
going on so that I'm on on camera ready
because you're going to get the usual
suspects. In fact, they're going to be
three groups of experts that'll show up.
So, here's a game you can play. It's
like a drinking game, but you're not old
enough to drink. So, drink orange juice
or coffee or whatever you have to drink.
So, watch an expert say, "Which group am
I going to put that expert in?" The
first
group are what I call the I told you so
experts. I hate them. Obnoxious people.
I told you so. The crash was coming. You
didn't listen to me. They're going to be
out in full force. When you see one of
those people, I would look at their
history to see how long they've been
saying
this. And most of them have been saying
this for 10 years, 11 years, and ask
yourself a question. If you'd been
listening to them all the way through,
would you be better off than doing what
you've done and actually going through a
crash? I'll wager. You're better off
doing what you did than going with them.
The second group is what I call
knee-jerk contrarians. You're going to
have people show up and say you need to
buy. Why? Because stocks are down.
That's it. That's their entire pitch.
It's knee-jerk because everything
anytime every something drops, you buy
it because you assume that's going to
bounce. It's like mean reversion on
steroids. And there's a third group
where there'll be a lot of hand ringing.
So on the one hand, on the other hand,
on the third hand, the fourth hand, the
fifth hand, by the time you get to the
ninth hand, you completely give up
because you're not sure whether they're
telling you stocks will go up, stocks
will go down, or stocks will stay where
they
are. A lot of market strategies you're
going to see in the next few sess, next
few weeks kind of play this role. Yeah,
we'll talk about it because in a sense
we'll talk about where to go next
because every one of us saying what do I
do
now? Now if you have if you have no
money of course you're not even asking
that question right so that's a
different so that's the first thing to
remember a lot of people have nothing in
the market what does he care whether
it's down 30% or up 30% right what you
choose to do will depend on three things
first it'll depend on how much you need
cash and when you need cash soon for
what a surgery for paying tuition for
buying a home for God's sakes don't wait
right now. Go and put in that sell
order. Get the cash now because waiting
for the right time is like playing
Russian roulette in this in a crisis
like this. So, if you need the cash,
it's out of your hands. You need to sell
now. If you don't need the cash, you
have the luxury of waiting. You might
not wait. You have the luxury of
waiting. Second, it'll depend on what
your macro views are and where this will
play out. And let's see the three three
extreme outcomes. So, first is a
full-scale trade war. tariffs, counter
tariffs, counter counter tariffs,
counter counter counter
tariffs. It's a worst case scenario. The
second is a partial trade war where some
countries get involved in a trade war
and the rest make
peace. Little more manageable. The third
is that the tariffs actually get pulled
off the table. That that rumor this
morning works out. you get a 90-day
pause and then another 90-day pause and
then No, I don't think the first and the
third are highly probable, but they can
happen. I think the second scenario is
the one that I think is most likely to
unfold. You think, but I have to be a
macroeconomist to forecast this. No,
it's got nothing to do with economics.
This is game theory, right?
I think if you're a really good poker
player, you have a better shot of
predicting which of those three will
come about than an economist because
that's the skill set you need. So cash
needs what you think about macro views.
Frankly, it depends on your investment
philosophy. Jake, what's your investment
philosophy? Buy the dip. Need your
contrarian then. Okay. And what is the
implicit assumption about markets that
leads you to buy the dip?
The implicit assumption is markets
overreact. Right? So anytime you invest
in philosophy, it's got to be built
about a belief about how markets make
mistakes and how they correct their
mistakes. Your philosophy should reflect
who you are as a person. So when you buy
the debt, what kind of personality do
you need to
have? Well, not necessarily optimistic.
You're probably the kind of kid that was
obnoxious right from the start. You did
the exact opposite of the rest of the
group, right? You're a contrarian.
You're the kind of kid that drives
teachers crazy from first grade to high
school, saying, you know, I asked you to
do things, you do the exact opposite.
You can't be a crowd follower, right?
You can't buy the dip if you're a crowd
follower because the pure group pressure
will keep you from doing it. I'm not
saying this is a good thing or a bad
thing. There's a personality type you
need for your flow. You see where this
is going, right? If you ask me what's
the right investment philosophy, what's
the answer to that? It depends on who
you are, what kind of person you are,
what you believe about markets. And what
you do in at this time will depend on
that philosophy. So you ask me a
question about what I'm going to do.
I'll tell you what I'm going to do. I'm
going to compute the equity risk premium
every day because that g you know how
Winnie the Pooh goes looking for
honey because it puts him in his happy
place. I don't quite have a happy place,
but I go looking for the daily. The
implied equity risk screen becomes my
equivalent of honey year. I need to find
it and then I can move on to the next
day. So, I'm going to do it every day.
I'm going to put it up on my web page.
I'll give you a link. So, it's through
Friday right now, but by later today, it
should be through today and then
tomorrow. So, each day I'll try to keep
it up and I'll keep it going till I say,
"Okay, it's pointless. It's kind of
leveled off." Okay. Second, I have
companies in my portfolio already. On
Wednesday, I felt pretty comfortable
about those companies either because
they were still undervalued or not
overvalued enough for me to sell them.
Could that have changed after the
trade? Why? Because the trade war is
going to change. Your earnings, your
cash flows, your revenue grow. I have
some really bad news for you. For those
of you who submitted your DCFS and you
did them before
Thursday, you might have to no oops
needed. You need to reexamine your
story, right? Could your story have
changed? If your supply chain runs
through, you're a US company and your
supply chain runs through Vietnam, you
might want to look at your story and
say, "What do I do now?" Yes. Sophia,
you got a question? Yeah.
Yeah.
See, here's the problem. What's next
year's crisis going to be on? We have no
idea, right? That's what makes valuation
exciting. Right now, we talk about
tariffs as if there I'll guarantee you a
year from now in teaching the guys,
tariffs won't be the center of the
universe. There'll be something else
that would have come in.
So these so I've got to revalue the
companies and perhaps some of them will
have to I'll have to get rid of them
even though the prices dropped the value
might have dropped even
more but there's every danger you know
creates opportunity right now remember
early in the class I talked about going
where it's darkest does it feel really
dark right
now I know the lights are on but you
know what I'm talking about right it
feels really uncertain really I
mean
and earlier in the class I also talked
about how great companies can be bad
investments. William, how can that
happen? How can a great company be a bad
investment? Because the price is too
high. What happens during a crisis?
People sell
everything. They're not discriminating.
Some of those great companies you've
always had on your list that haven't
made it now might be
buyable. Few weeks ago when I wrote
about globalization and disruption and I
value
Tesla, you remember what I told you I
sold Tesla after the election. Do you me
remember the company I mentioned as a
company I would like to buy? I talked
about BYD. Brian here is a big fan of
BYD. He's been trying to get me to buy
BYD right from the start of this class.
And I said, I really like the company,
but Brian, do you remember where why I
held
back? I said the no that I'm willing to
live because it's politics both ways.
It's government's so I used to not
invest in Chinese companies because I
said the government is part of my story,
but if I buy Tesla, government is part
of my story anyway, right? So I'm
willing to look past that now.
So when I valued BYD three weeks ago on
the ADR, I came up with a value of like
$80 per share. Stock was trading at 100
and I said I like the company, but I put
in a limit buy with good till cancelled
at $75 then and I assumed that there was
zero chance it would ever get there.
Know what that zero chance is looking
like? Not zero now, right? It's not
quite there, but it's starting to move
down. I don't know what BYD ended at,
the ADR ended at, but I think it was at
88 on Friday. It might be all I know.
80.72. We're getting really close. One
more f day like last Friday. I'm there.
Right. So, and you know why I made it a
limit
buy? Because if you have to buy it, you
will never pull the trigger. Right? So,
BYD and Marcado Libé, which is the stock
I put up as my stock for this week. Take
a look at it. Great company, overvalued
last week, but could become undervalued
this week. So, I will see you on
Wednesday. Marcado was um
portfolio. If you do, you should buy a
portfolio and get done, right? If you
have a lot of opportunities, then you
can pick a
juice. Anytime you put in a margin of
safety, it's because you have too many
opportunities and little money. So
that's really
and like what are the cats that you look
for when you're seeing when you're kind
of determining whether